[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich habe für euch eine
orio sahnetorte die super schnell
gemacht ist und noch nicht mal in den
ofen muss für dieses rezept nehmen wir
uns für den boden außerdem eine leckere
sahne creme die wir anschließend für das
topping zu einer schokocreme verwandelt
und dann wird das ganze mit loriots
getoppt die torte ist supereinfach und
damit auch wunderbar für anfänger
geeignet
nun kommt er aber mal zu den zutaten für
den boden benötigen wir oreo kekse und
ein paar habe ich mir schon zur seite
gelegt für die deko außerdem
geschmolzene butter und für die leckere
sahne creme benötigen wie kalte
schlagsahne etwas magerquark mascarpone
zum süßen gezuckerte kondensmilch
vanille extrakt oder vanille zucker
etwas sahne stand mittel und für das
topping später noch ein wenig bergauf
zuallererst wird der boden vorbereitet
und hierfür geben wir die oreo kekse
komplett mit creme einmal in unseren
ländern
und dann müssen wir das ganze richtig
schön fein
sobald dann die oreo kekse schön feiern
gemixt wurden geben wir die flüssige
butter mit hinzu
[Musik]
sobald sich dann die zwei zutaten
miteinander verbunden haben ist unser
boden auch schon vorbereitet jetzt habe
ich mir einen bug ring auf meine
tortenplatte gelegt und gäbe da den
kompletten orio boden hinein und drücke
ihn schön fest
[Musik]
das funktioniert am besten mit einem
glas und sobald ihr das ganze dann schön
fest angedrückt habt ist euer boden auch
schon fertig und kann bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
die mascarpone sahne creme ist auch
super schnell hergestellt wir geben
zuallererst mascarpone und magerquark in
unsere rührschüssel an der stelle gebe
ich auch noch den vanille extrakt und
unsere gezuckerte kondensmilch dazu die
zwei zutaten sorgen für die süße mir
persönlich ist das schon süß genug und
allen anderen in der familie auch aber
wenn ihr das ganze süßes gibt gerne
etwas puderzucker mit hinzu danach kommt
auch die schlagsahne mit hinzu und wenn
alle zutaten schön kalt aus dem
kühlschrank kommen dann kann auch nichts
schief gehen jetzt wird das ganze auf
niedriger stufe erst mal so lange
verrührt bis die zutaten sich
einigermaßen miteinander verbunden haben
[Musik]
nach wenigen momenten geben wir auch
schon dass seine stand mittel mit hinein
und dann erhöhen wir die stufe gehen auf
die allerhöchste und lassen das ganze
richtig schön steif schlagen
[Musik]
nach nur 12 minuten ist unsere
mascarpone sahne creme dann auch schon
fertig und kann auf den orio boden
gegeben werden einen kleinen teil der
sahne creme lasse ich allerdings noch in
der schüssel denn den benötigen wir
später noch für schoko topping wer noch
zusätzlich in orio geschmack in der
sahne creme haben möchte der kann an der
stelle noch gehackte urus mit hinzugeben
zudem können früchte fans auch an der
stelle noch zum beispiel erdbeeren oder
bananen oder sonstige früchte mit
hinzugeben
sobald die oberfläche dann schön glatt
gestrichen wurde geht es auch schon
weiter
jetzt muss die orio tor tippe mindestens
zwei stunden in den kühlschrank je
länger sie im kühlschrank ist desto
fester wird sie mit der übrig
gebliebenen sahne machen wir jetzt einen
schoko topping und dafür geben wir unser
bacau hinein und heben das gut unter
das topping muss ebenfalls gekühlt
werden da es ja aus sahne besteht und
sobald dann auch die kühe zeit rum ist
und ihr den bug kling entfernen können
fehlt nur noch die dekoration damit die
ränder der torte jetzt auch schön gerade
sind streiche ich sie noch mal glatt mit
meiner winkel palette und dann geht es
auch schon weiter mit dem frosting
[Musik]
für die dekoration nämlich einen
spritzbeutel mit einer offenen stelle
und spritzte damit zwölf dekorative
rosetten
[Musik]
die hausse die ich mir anfangs zur seite
gelegt habe habe ich durch zwei geteilt
und geben sie jetzt auf mein schoko
frosting
[Musik]
doriot sahnetorte hält sich im
kühlschrank bis zu drei tage ich bin mir
sicher dass wir sie allerdings schon am
ersten tag vollständig vernascht vom
geschmack her und vom zeitaufwand hat
mich die torte total überzeugt denn ihr
habt mit wenig aufwand eine
kinderleichte und super leckere oreo
torte
[Musik]
falls ihr jetzt auch lust habt die orio
sahnetorte nachzumachen dann schaut gern
mal unten in die infobox dort habe ich
für euch wie immer alle genauen
mengenangaben aufgeschrieben
ansonsten danke ich euch fürs
einschalten wünsche euch ganz viel
freude beim nachmachen und sagt bis zum
nächsten mal auf geht s kitchen